in the continuing gongshow of
international diplomacy that is being
put on by President Donald Trump he has
yet again embarrassed the United States
with a hat trick of shame I'm calling it
a hat trick plus-one there was a little
bone it's call it an overtime involving
the German Chancellor Angela Merkel
basically the new leader of the free
world is Angela Merkel as I've talked
about before as a result of Donald
Trump's election in the United States as
president and during Merkel's visit
Donald Trump referred to the United
States as a company called a German
media outlet fake news very awkwardly
refused to shake on gula Merkel's hand
in the Oval Office and then also here's
the bonus did the same thing as what we
observed with his meeting with the
Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a
wear during the sort of two podiums
speech that goes on Trump was seemingly
not noticing or not caring that he
couldn't understand the language that
the world leader was speaking and only
after a time to Donald Trump opted to
put in his earpiece to pretend like he
cared even 1% what his fellow world
leader was saying but let's work up to
that okay it might be a little too much
cringe to die right into the handshake
debacle and the German debacle right
away so let's start with calling the
United States a company this is the most
minor of the gaffes here it is we're a
very powerful company country were very
strong very strong country yes we know
Donald you see this as running a company
that's why your ideas would run it into
the ground like he has done with many
companies before then a German reporter
asked Donald Trump about his misuse of
the term fake news and about wiretapping
Trump responds directly by saying that
her question or her premise or her media
outlet or whatever it's an example of
fake news q Donald a fair trader I am a
trader that wants to see good for
everybody worldwide but I am NOT an
isolationist by any stretch of the
imagination so I don't know what you
newspaper are you're reading but I guess
that would be another example of as you
say
shake dues there it is classic little
tidbit to add the reporter was from
developed the most pro-american
newspaper arguably in all of Germany and
now the cherry on top the refusal to
shake Angela Merkel's hand since it may
be difficult to hear because there's a
lot of background noise or you may be
listening to the podcast or the radio
I'll preview what happens in what I'm
about to play for you the photographers
say can we get a handshake so Angela
Merkel turns to Trump and says do you
want to have a handshake Trump doesn't
even look over he just looks straight
ahead and watch Angela Merkel space if
you're watching with us where she just
projects the total confusion which is
obviously what many people in the room
were feeling let's take a look thank you
[Applause]
let's look at it one more time okay so
now this time check check the look on
Angela Merkel's face when she looks back
to her right which can only be described
as a sort of WTF look I mean it is just
very very strange very bizarre here and
I noticed that Trump constantly looked
during this thing like it was almost
difficult for him to look at Angela
Merkel wasn't this just a bizarre series
of events Pat it certainly was luckily
they shook hands later but I would have
loved it if Angela Merkel reached out
for the handshake anyway yeah because
there's no chance that Trump would have
denied her that well she is a
professional diplomat so she knew rather
than expose myself by reaching out I'll
ask Trump whether he wants to do the
handshake so I don't end up with my hand
in the air but Trump is looking straight
ahead like she's not even talking to him
and how insulting is that just to ignore
her altogether not even to offer a
handshake in the Oval Office where
you're greeting her but also just to
ignore her comment there so there's the
hat-trick of hilarity and here is our
overtime our fourth instance no Trump
press conference where the foreign
leader is complete until Donald Trump
pretends to be understanding the foreign
language that the diplomat is speaking
I'm going to play a little video for you
here you will hear on Lola Merkel's
start to talk in German then you will
hear the translation that is happening
what Trump can't hear that you'll see
once again just like with Shinzo Abe a
Trump goes nearly half a minute
looking around and sort of acting like
he either understands German or doesn't
care what Angela Merkel is saying until
I'm guessing someone signals him to put
the damn earpiece in which he ultimately
does then Mohandas off when we speak
about trade agreements then the European
Union is negotiating those agreements
for all of the members of the European
Union but obviously there's also input
by the member states they bring to the
table what important to them
we have underlined as an German in the
street and business community and have
made the experience that any
kind of agreement that we have concluded
for example at the very latest at with
South Korea brought us more jobs
actually people are very much concerned
this is the best he thought it was a
higher priority at one point he adjusts
his suit jacket he thought that was more
of a high priority than figuring out why
he can't understand what Angela Merkel
is saying I guess we're not going to
give him the benefit of the doubt that
maybe he understands some German no I
don't think I don't think that he has
earned that benefit of the doubt what a
disaster once again the entire entire
world is laughing at our president and
his supporters in the u.s. some of them
anyway
not all his approval rating is down
we'll talk about that later but at least
some of the trumpets become emboldened
and feel like they're voting for Trump
is justified by the fact that the world
is laughing at us how could these
incidents get worse I mean it's close to
as bad as it could get he could have
completed the issue where Angela Merkel
was wiretapped by Obama with the
controversy going on with him yeah right
of course back in 2010 the NSA during
President Obama's presidency was
surveilling Angela Merkel's
communications there was evidence for
that we know that to have been true
contrast that with Donald Trump's
wiretapping allegations no evidence and
increasingly denied by one Intelligence
Agency after another
Angela Merkel if I were ongal Merkel I'd
probably be thrilled that Trump
continues to make a fool out of himself
expect especially standing right next to
her it just makes her look better in
comparison